london kurz vor den olympischen spielen
in der u-bahn erfasst eine
überwachungskamera diese frau mit
koffern
sie verhält sich verdächtig
ich habe ihre überwachungskamera
gewidmet
ich bin die mit den geldern koffer
wie wäre es mit einer patenschaft
terroranschlag oder spiel
die zürcher künstlergruppe picknick hat
sich in die überwachungskamera gehackt
wie ist das wenn du dathe strom
produziert das die metric sind da hatte
die flüsse und irgendwo vom stadtring a
spielte mit radium scheibe hat sie immer
neu an allerlei eine neue weltweite und
das sind so momente ist ein auf ihn
interessiere was wenn mir quasi kathrin
stricker verhandelte drehen
nicht erst seit machen sich künstler
gedanken darüber wie daten missbraucht
werden können
das künstlerpaar beatnik hakt sich in
systeme rein um zu zeigen wer wie von
digitalen informationen profitiert und
wie einfach diese systeme zu knacken
sind wieder london auch 2012
wikileaks-gründer julian assange
flüchtet in die ecuadorianische
botschaft er fürchtet eine auslieferung
an die usa hatte er doch geheime us
regierungsdokumente veröffentlicht
die britische polizei droht ihn zu
verhaften via livestream verfolgen die
beiden zürcher medienkünstler das
geschehen
dann plötzlich passiert etwas
eigenartiges ein pizza kurier taucht auf
und marschiert direkt auf den eingang
der botschaft zu wer hat ihn bestellt
online verfolgte picknick mit die hacker
versuchten ins geschehen einzugreifen
auf websites wie vor 10 formierten sich
communitys die für assange anonym pizzas
oder taxis losschicken
ein banaler scherz mitten in einer
hochexplosiven krise das ganze
straßenzug taxi taxi autos graf
botschaft verstanden sind und schauten
am ausstand sich halt dass wir sehr
seriös straßburg sie für den moment und
brav daheim mehrweg merkt es gibt somit
kann sich durch muss also zu so
geopolitische thema verhallt kunst
inspiriert von hacker logik gab es einen
weg zur sound vorzudringen
mit nicks einfache lösung ein päckchen
adressiert an julien assange ecotel
darin eingebaut eine kamera mit gps die
den weg des paketes dokumentiert und die
bilder live online stellt
im london aufgegeben ist es zwei tage
lang unterwegs
ausgang ungewiss und die letzte stunde
diesen dem zug bringt denn sie sind
aufgesprungen tisch fast explodiert
friedrich das recht groß und und hätte
ich den anfang recht langsam so richtig
schön assange bewegen
das paket landet dann tatsächlich in der
scharf bewachten ecuadorianischen
botschaft bei juliane hanisch
die aktion delivery tum ist es am anfang
dieses jahres in zürich gezeigt ist ein
aufruf für transparenz und gegen
überwachung
dazu haben sie auch den raum nachgebaut
in dem es seit zwei jahren fest sitzt
ein symbol des widerstandes das picknick
mit einfachen digitalen mitteln
öffentlich gemacht hat